sie planen einen eigenen Staat träumen
von sich selbst versorgenden
Gemeinschaften ganzen Dörfern und sie
lehnen die deutschen Gesetze ab ich gebe
es kein Rechtsstaat ist ein
staats-simulation ein Konstrukt
sie glauben an die Regeln eines
ausgedachten Königreichs basteln sich
fantasie-dokumente und pseudogesetze das
ist einfach nur die Verfassung die sie
vertreten es sind Reichsbürger die im
Netz offensiv für sich werben bei Fragen
dazu doch lieber schweigen wenn ich
sagen warum sie im letzten April aus dem
System ausgestiegen sind nein das möchte
ich nicht ich sage am besten gar nichts
und sie betreiben Firmen Praxen und
Geschäfte ohne Gewerbeanmeldung und
Genehmigungen
bringen Sie frische Ware heute die
Behörden wissen davon und tun sich
schwer der wohl bundesweit größten
reichsbürgergruppe zu begegnen deren
selbst ernannte Anführer verbreitet
nicht nur verschwörungserzählungen auch
Extremisten können Land kaufen oder
versuchen Mitglieder einer
Genossenschaft zu werden es gibt eine
Bestrebung
überregionale Strukturen auszubilden und
das geht dann eben bis hin zu dem
Versuch quasi den Staat in Gänze
rumzustürzen wir finden Unternehmer und
Geschäftsleute die den deutschen Staat
und seine Verwaltung ablehnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Tangermünde im Norden von Sachsen-Anhalt
die alte Hansestadt hat gut 10.000
Einwohner ist eine touristische Perle
Ziel für Radtouristen und Wassersportler
[Musik]
nahe des wohnmobilparkplatzes an der
Elbe an einem unscheinbaren Haus mit
gelber Tür beginnt unsere Spurensuche
ein kleiner Laden wer hier einkauft so
steht es im Aushang wird angeblich
staatszugehöriger des krd des
sogenannten Königreichs Deutschland das
ist die wohl bundesweit größte
Gruppierung von reichsbürgern
wir haben kein Interesse darum möchte
ich Sie bitten sich bitte zu entfernen
von unserem Gebäude eigentlich ist der
Laden geöffnet doch nicht für uns
erklärt uns der Betreiber Herr G als er
die Kamera entdeckt über sein Geschäft
im ausgedachten Königreich reden will er
nicht und wer wäre die Pressestelle weil
das hat mich jetzt sozusagen erstaunt
dass wir irgendwie noch eine
Pressestelle haben oder habe ich das
falsch verstanden nee so weit sind wir
noch nicht vom haben wir noch keine
Pressestelle
aber ich denke sie sind hier wegen dem
Königreich Deutschland die haben eine
offizielle Pressestelle mit denen haben
Sie auch schon Interviews geführt von
daher wissen Sie wohin sie sich wenden
müssen ich möchte jetzt mit ihnen nicht
weiter reden ich möchte mit ihnen nicht
weiter reden gut weil sie sagen wir ich
möchte mit ihnen nicht weiter reden
kurz sprechen kann ich mit zwei
Kundinnen die gerade Brot im Laden
gekauft haben sie gesehen wo Sie
eingekauft haben
ja ja
die Aushänge am Laden hätten sie gesehen
mit reichsbürgern hätten sie das
Geschäft nicht in Verbindung gebracht
erzählen sie
wir schauen uns die Webseite des
Lebensmittelladens an dort präsentiert
ein Online-Shop Aufstriche Saft und Brot
alles ohne Angabe einer Währung
zur Abholung an Verteilstationen in der
Region
im Impressum wird als angeblicher
Aufsichtsbehörde das sogenannte
Königreich Deutschland genannt
ein Laden betrieben von reichsbürgern in
zentraler Lage wie kann das sein
[Musik]
das will ich von Tangermünde des
Bürgermeister Steffen schilm wissen er
erklärt die Stadt wisse seit einem
halben Jahr von dem Laden im Januar aber
das Gewerbeamt das Geschäft kontrolliert
nun sind halt so dass die Kollegen
einfach versichert haben es geht kein
Gewerbeanmeldung vor der Unternehmer der
dort tätig ist wurde aufgefordert seine
Unterlagen jetzt einzureichen und da
gibt es eine Frist und wenn er die Frist
einhält und seine notwendige Unterlagen
einreicht dann kann er damit durchaus
weitermachen mit dem was hat das ist
nichts was jetzt sofort untersagt werden
müsste keine Gewerbeanmeldung und keine
Meldung zu Lebensmittelhygiene trotzdem
ist der Laden seit Monaten geöffnet das
sagt uns der Bürgermeister Anfang März
wir werden später noch einmal mit ihm
sprechen
der Lebensmittelladen in Tangermünde ist
Teil einer Strategie des sogenannten
Königreichs Deutschland
diese reichsbürgergruppierung
präsentiert sich auf eigenen Webseiten
mit Videos die an Start-up Werbung
erinnern in ihnen wirkt das selbst
ernannte Oberhaupt Peter Fitzek um
Selbstständige und Unternehmer mit
falschen Versprechungen und Behauptungen
da muss ich nicht erklären da braucht
kein Steuerberater er muss nie zum
Finanzamt und er kriegt kein Ärger er
braucht keine Gewerbeanmeldung und bei
uns braucht auch keine Steuern das ist
falsch und tatsächlich geht es im
Fantasie Königreich um viel Geld und
liegt eine Liste vor mit Preisen allein
der
pseudo-staatsbürgerausweis soll hunderte
Euro kosten
und in dem Streben den deutschen nach
über 60 Jahren wieder eine Heimat in
wahrer Freiheit zu geben bereits 2012
ruft der gelernte Koch Peter Fitzek den
Fantasie statt aus vor hunderten
Anhängern in einer alten Industriehalle
und im Faschingskostüm mit Krone erklärt
er sich zu Peter dem ersten
ein ehemaliges Krankenhaus in Wittenberg
wird zunächst fiktives Reichsgebiet
weder das Grundgesetz noch deutsche
Justiz sollen hier gelten
stattdessen erfindet Fitzek eigene
Institutionen eine Bank vermeintliche
Staatsbetriebe oder eine
Krankenversicherung die Bankgeschäfte
werden ihm untersagt mehrfach landet
Fitzek vor Gericht Fahren ohne
Führerschein Urkundenfälschung
unerlaubte versicherungsgeschäfte
[Musik]
wegen schwerer Untreue kommt der 2 Jahre
in Haft bis Anfang 2019
etwa dem Verurteilten rechtsextremen
Blogger Nikolai nähling
je mehr sich abkehren vom alten System
und die Größe unseres System wird desto
schneller werden wir alle frei von
diesen satanischen Struktur satanische
Strukturen für Fitzek des deutschen
Staats und Rechtssystem
und profitieren und Peter Fitzek
verbreitet antisemitische
verschwörungserzählungen in diesem Video
behauptet er eine jüdische Organisation
schüre Kriege um eine satanistische
Weltordnung zu schaffen diese Fronten
sollen aufgebaut werden und sie werden
von einer im Hintergrund stehende
Organisation aufgebaut die man Rabatten
nennt wenn man sich mal anschaut von wem
her Putin erzogen wurde dann weiß man
dass Herr Putin von noch Rabatt zweites
Kind erzogen wurde wenn man mal schaut
wäre selinski ist er war früher ein
Schauspieler und er hat den Präsidenten
gespielt das macht er offensichtlich
ganz gut genau aber er ist auch im
Prinzip jüdischer Abstammung und Teil
der Rabatt im Video zeigt dazu Fotos
vermeintlicher rabina und mutmaßlich
jüdischer Gottesdienste
darauf wartet Peter Fitzek lässt einen
zutiefst antisemitisches Weltbild
erkennen indem dann erstmal
grundsätzlich die Welt immer aufgeteilt
wird in auf der einen Seite die guten
Menschen und auf der anderen Seite die
bösen die Satanisten und die Satanisten
das ist nicht nur so gemeint im
religiösen Sinne sondern das ist
eigentlich eine Chiffre ein Code der in
verschiedenen einzelnen Reden von Fitzek
immer wieder auch mit jüdischen
Verbindungen genutzt wurde wenn Jamin
Winkler ist Experte für
Verschwörungsideologien bei der amadeo
Antonio Stiftung zwar gebe sich das
sogenannte Königreich Deutschland
gewaltfrei tatsächlich aber sei Fitzeks
antisemitisches Weltbild gefährlich
damit ist natürlich auch dieses
Königreich direkt eine Gefahr für
jüdische Menschen in Deutschland weil
der Antisemitismus dadurch salonfähig
gemacht wird und man überhaupt nicht
ausschließen kann ob da nicht einzelne
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter oder auch
NutzerInnen Nutzer des Königreich direkt
zum offenen aggressiven auch gegen Juden
über wechseln Kontakte zu
Rechtsextremisten Antisemitismus
Vorwürfe und Vorstrafen des
möchtegernkönigs dennoch wächst die
reichsbürgerbewegung sagt Jochen
Hollmann er leitet in Sachsen-Anhalt den
Verfassungsschutz dieser schätzt die
Szene der Reichsbürger und
Selbstverwalter bundesweit auf
mittlerweile 23.000 Menschen sorge
bereitet uns aber der doch gerade in den
letzten Jahren zu verzeichnet zu
verzeichnende Zulauf sei es das
Privatpersonen sind oder auch das ist
Gewerbetreibende beim Königreich
mitmachen wollen und sich damit auch aus
dem Steuersystem und auch dem generell
dem dem bundesrepublikanischen System
abmelden und es ist auch erklärtes Ziel
seit Jahren dass man Ländereien kaufen
will mit Wasseranschluss mit
Möglichkeiten ein möglichst autarkes
Leben zu führen
mit Hochglanz Videos präsentieren die
Reichsbürger sich und ihre neue
Werbungen wollen so für ihre
Gemeinschaft werden Vergangenes Jahr
kauften sie zwei Grundstücke in Sachsen
mit ackerwald und Wasserflächen ein
Hotel sowie ein Schloss Kaufpreis rund
3,6 Millionen Euro das Geld
bereitgestellt von Menschen die an den
Fantasie statt glauben
große Gemeinschaften die das sehr schön
welche Menschen zieht es ins
reichsbürgermilieu darüber gäbe es wenig
Erkenntnis sagt Benjamin Winkler klar
sei es sind überwiegend Männer ab dem 40
Lebensjahr wir haben es häufig mit
Personen zu tun die in irgendeiner Weise
ein Bruch in ihrer biografievorweisen
und dieser Bruch das können ganz
verschiedene Momente sein das kann zum
Beispiel ein wirtschaftlicher
Zusammenbruch sein dass jemand versucht
hat sich selbstständig zu machen und das
ist gescheitert das kann sein dass
jemand familiär die eigene Beziehung
von Baum gefahren hat und das scheint
eben dann diese reichsideologie dieser
Zugang zur Szene das scheint dann für
viele wie eine Art Heilung auch zu sein
ja wie so eine Art neuer Weg den man
dann eben einschlägt
um ein eigenes Wirtschaftssystem zu
schaffen betreibt fit6 fantasiestaat
eine Plattform für Unternehmer und
Selbstständige laut eigenen Angaben
bieten hier rund 390 Personen und Firmen
ihre Dienste an und sie seien Teil der
reichsbürgergruppierung so die
Erläuterung
in diesem Verzeichnis wirkt auch eine
Heilpraktikerin aus Magdeburg für sich
auch auf ihre eigenen Firmenwebseite
sieht sie ihre Geschäfte im fiktiven
reichsbürgerstaat ihre Gewerbe in der
Bundesrepublik habe vs letzten April
abgemeldet erfahren wir von der
zuständigen Stadt warum abends nach
einem ihrer Kurse wollen wir die
Heilpraktikerin dazu sprechen
aber das möchte ich nicht erklären warum
sie Unternehmen in Deutschland alles was
Sie wissen müssen können Sie auf der
Homepage vom Königreich Deutschland Ort
lesen oder auf meiner Homepage mehr
möchte ich dazu nichts sagen weil ich
sagen warum sie im letzten April aus dem
System ausgestiegen sind nein das möchte
ich nicht sie können da gerne andere
Fragen aber ich möchte das nicht
werden sie den aktiv auch ich möchte mit
ihnen nicht sprechen okay also schönen
Abend und das Telefon ist
auf ihrem Telegramm Kanal erklärt sich
die Therapeutin tatsächlich um frei zu
leben schreibt sie dort habe sie ein
Unternehmen im Königreich Deutschland
gegründet so könne sie steuerfrei und
selbstbestimmt arbeiten und hier wirbt
sie auch für die reichsbürgergruppierung
auf schriftliche Nachfragen dazu
antwortet sie nicht dafür bietet sie
weiter Kurse an ohne Gewerbeanmeldung
wir fragen noch einmal bei der
zuständigen Stadt Magdeburg nach die
erklärt sie habe die Praxis Ende März
kontrolliert Zitat ein Hinweis auf eine
Ausübung als Heilpraktikerin fand sich
nicht wir werden zeitnah eine erneute
Kontrolle vornehmen
[Musik]
wir wollen wissen was Menschen wie die
Heilpraktikerin in die reichsbürgerszene
lockt wir fahren nach Lutherstadt
Wittenberg zur Adresse des fiktiven
Königreichs auf dem Gelände einer alten
Konservenfabrik laden die Reichsbürger
zum Infotag
hier sollten Sie erstmal nicht
reinfilmen oh warum erlaubt ja wir
dürfen nicht hinein auch ein Interview
mit Peter Fitzek bekommen wir nicht aber
einen Aufpasser er gehöre zum Kernteam
hier sagt er sie sind ich bin Benjamin
und nur wenn ihr mir genau
ich bin jetzt sicher schaust mal dass
hier alles mit rechten Ding zu läuft
auch jetzt das ist auch die Menschen ja
nicht belästigt werden das ist meine
Funktion heute hier
Benjamin Müller heißt der Mann mit
vollem Namen sagt von sich er gehöre
seit anderthalb Jahren zum ausgedachten
Königreich
zweimal im Jahr laden die Reichsbürger
in Wittenberg zum Besuch und
präsentieren sich mit Vorträgen zum
angeblichen Systemausstieg und zu
fiktiven Staatsbetrieben auf dem
Parkplatz Autos aus dem ganzen
Bundesgebiet je fast zur Hälfte aus Ost
und West von den angereisten wollen
jedoch nur wenige Reden sind
sie nicht nein
Information interessant
sie haben keine Lust zu reden heute ist
sozusagen das erste Mal dass ich
sozusagen persönlich hier vor Ort mir
das angucken und
was ich so super klasse finde durch die
gute Energie wenn Menschen
zusammenstehen können wir so viel
erreichen dass die Chemtrails sich
auflösen
Chemtrails gemeint ist eine
verschwörungserzählung die besagt das
Flugzeuge mit Kondensstreifen
Chemikalien versprühen angebliche Eliten
würden so wahlweise das Klima oder gar
unsere Gedanken kontrollieren
oh das ist nicht antworten das ist vom
ZDF die möchten hier gewisse Fragen
stellen sage
genau
die Leute fragen dann bitte ich möchte
sagen
sie zweimal getan
wiederholt unterbricht der aufpassen
Benjamin Müller unsere Gespräche sie
lassen uns unsere Arbeit nicht machen an
der Stelle
hätten wir sie was fragen auf die
Schnelle ich komme aus Norddeutschland
aus Niedersachsen Meinhard Mitte 20
Angestellter Elektriker er plant eine
Betriebsgründung im fantasie-königreich
was war das Interesse oder ist das
Interesse
ich wollte mich selbstständig machen und
interessiere mich wie ich halt auch das
ganze Steuerrecht deutlich vereinfachen
könnte darum erstmal und das ist hier
halt deutlich einfacher aber hier sagen
sie einfach Zeit gar nicht
Steuerhinterziehung sieht er darin nicht
und er erzählt was ihm die
Betriebsgründung kosten würde denn der
fantasiestaat verlangt Geld für die
angebliche Staatsbürgerschaft für
Seminare für erfundene Dokumente
50 Euro
Bereich
dennoch sei die vermeintlich legale
Betriebsgründung im Reichsbürger statt
günstiger als in der ungeliebten BRD
bekommen
das ist Grundgesetz sozusagen hinter den
hinter den Mauern keine gelungen hat
gibt ihn nicht zu denken
nee dafür haben wir dann die Verfassung
was anderes danke
eine Mischung aus Sekte und finanziellem
Schneeballsystem so sehen Experten und
Verfassungsschutz die reichsbürgergruppe
aus Wittenberg die auch mit dem Verkauf
von phantasie-dokumenten Geld einnimmt
den Systemausstieg zu verstehen
aus Geld
[Musik]
viele Dinge die auch wieder dieses
System Geld kosten von daher Personal
tatsächlich verlangt die
reichsbürgergruppe für ihren
ausgedachten bürgerausweis 480 €. die
fiktive Betriebsgründung kostet 1.650 €
wohlgemerkt für Fantasie Dokumente am
Parkplatz spreche ich eine Frau die
anonym bleiben will die 64-Jährige kommt
aus der Nähe von Berlin sie sei
Rentnerin müsse jedoch hinzuverdienen am
Fantasie statt der Reichsbürger
interessiere sie der vermeintlich
alternative Leben sind Wurf
ich bin wirklich auf der Suche wie man
das System der Organisation der Menschen
des Miteinanders so machen kann dass es
friedlich und füreinander ist sie habe
heute Vorträge gehört auch zum
sogenannten Systemausstieg
reichsbürgerideen habe sie darin nicht
entdeckt also ich habe das so verstanden
dass das alles existiert ja aber sie
haben so einen Paragraphen genommen
wonach sie auf einem bestimmten Gebiet
sich was Eigenes machen können dass das
rechtens wäre also wenn ich jetzt im
Internet gucke dann staune ich wie lange
es schon was gibt vom Königreich
Deutschland wenn das nicht rechtens ist
warum gibt es das denn dann schon so
viele Jahre verstehe ich nicht also
Peter Fitze nutzt hier natürlich auch
die Langsamkeit der Justiz letztendlich
aus ne in dem einfach Verfahren nach
mühsamer Recherche und so weiter
abgeschlossen ist und das nächste auch
wieder Jahre braucht ist dann vor
Gericht zur nächsten Verhandlung kommt
und das suggeriert auch eine gewisse
Legitimität und Legalität und ich glaube
das ist ja gerade für Menschen aus der
bürgerlichen Mitte wichtig dass Sie
wissen sie haben sich jetzt hier nicht
einem Extremisten verschrieben
[Musik]
der Zulauf auch zu fit sechs
reichsbürgergruppe hält an trotz einer
Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz
[Musik]
Sachsen-Anhalts Innenministerin Tamara
ziesang warnter vor Reichsbürger zu
verharmlosen über ein Verbot des
sogenannten Königreichs Deutschland will
sie nicht reden das zeigt doch dass das
so illegal nicht sein kann sagen uns die
Leute dann also diejenigen die sich
angesprochen fühlen was was antworten
Sie denn sie müsste differenzieren nicht
jeder Extremist ist automatisch
als die strafrechtlich relevant aktiv in
dem von ihm beschriebenen Fall ist es in
Teilen so deswegen sind ja auch diverse
Strafverfahren und einiges gelaufen aber
der Verfassungsschutz guckt hier auch im
Vorfeld ist eine Gefährdung für die
Demokratie da ich kann natürlich nichts
daran ändern wenn ein Bürger einfach
behauptet da sei man nie tätig geworden
dass man dort tätig geworden ist kann
man zum einen Verfassungsschutzbericht
nachlesen aber es gibt eben auch diverse
Verurteilung und die sprechen ja auch
eine deutliche Sprache Versäumnisse
seitens der Politik und der Behörden
sieht die Innenministerin nicht
wir sind noch einmal in Tangermünde vier
Wochen nach unserem ersten Besuch der
Lebensmittelladen ist geschlossen hallo
in den Baulärm und Licht doch niemand
öffnet
ein Schild an der Tür erklärt das
Geschäft werde zum Treffpunkt umgebaut
Lebensmittel würden künftig nur noch
online gehandelt
im Rathaus treffen wir noch einmal den
Bürgermeister Steffen schilm und fragen
was die Stadt seit unserem letzten
Gespräch unternommen hat die hätte eine
Gewerbeanmeldung eingefordert der
Ladenbesitzer schickte daraufhin diese
fantasie-dokumente und heute ist es so
dass wir mittlerweile dann nachdem die
Frist verstrichen wurde oder verstrichen
ist
ein Bußgeldverfahren eingeleitet haben
und das Bußgeldverfahren läuft jetzt und
nun gibt es wieder Fristen und schauen
uns an wie das da weitergeht im
Ladenbesitzer hat die Stadt ein Bußgeld
von 500 € angedroht die rechtlichen
Möglichkeiten seinen begrenzt sagt der
Bürgermeister er habe zudem auch andere
Behörden informiert
und Kollegen auch machen das
Gesundheitsamt das Veterinäramt
Landesamt für Verbraucherschutz
informiert wir haben es beordnungsamt
informiert weil es möglicherweise dort
noch eine Umnutzung stattgefunden hat
und und solche also diese über diese
Behörden haben wir in jedem Fall mit den
Kenntnis gesetzt wir waren jetzt auch
dabei und haben das Landesverwaltungsamt
darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt damit auch
dort beim Land die Kenntnis über das
Treiben das ja Unternehmers dort bekannt
ist welche Reaktion da gab es noch keine
Reaktion wir haben das erstmal wir haben
das alles schriftlich dort eingereicht
und wir warten jetzt drauf dass da
Bewegung reinkommt und der
Verfassungsschutz habe erst vor wenigen
Tagen ein Gespräch angeboten dabei
fordert selbst das zuständige
Innenministerium auf seiner Webseite
konsequent des Handeln aller Betroffenen
Verwaltungsbehörden
gelingt das auch in Tangermünde wir
fragen noch einmal bei der
Innenministerin nach zu dem Fall der
Betroffenen Verwaltungsbehörden die
haben wir dann nicht reagiert ist das
richtig also nicht angemessen reagiert
oder sehen halten Sie das für angemessen
sie behaupten dass ich kenne das jetzt
nicht und insofern geht es mir darum
sie haben am Anfang gefragt wie
informieren wir wir informieren
regelmäßig über die reichsbürgerszene
und natürlich weiß ich auch dass dadurch
dass es Kommunalwahlen in
unterschiedlichen Abständen gibt kommen
auch immer wieder andere Personen in
Verantwortung die dann vielleicht an der
einen oder anderen
Informationsveranstaltung an dem ein
oder andere Informationsangebot noch
nicht teilnehmen konnten wir müssen
wirklich an der Stelle auch noch mal
überprüfen ob die Angebote auch wirklich
von den Bürgermeisterinnen und
Bürgermeister dann genutzt werden und
wenn sie nicht genutzt werden warum
werden sie nicht genutzt ja sind sie zu
fremd sind sie zu weit weg sind sie
vielleicht zu unverständlich formuliert
das ist schon wichtig im Umgang mit
reichsbürgern müssten Bürgermeister
Kommunalverwaltung Landesbehörden
gemeinsam handeln zusammen mit den
Bürgern und Bürgerinnen vor Ort
wie das gehen kann zeigt das Beispiel
Ruthenberg in Brandenburg im Herbst
letzten Jahres spricht sich im 3000
Einwohner Ort herum das fitx
fantasiereich hier Grundstücke kaufen
will
der Gasthof und ein
Landwirtschaftsbetrieb samt 44 Hektar
stehen zum Verkauf die Reichsbürger
wollten die Immobilie zur
Selbstversorgung nutzen glaubt der
Verfassungsschutz
wenn Anhänger einer Reichsbürger
Bestrebung
auch formal legalen Weg probieren
irgendwie an Land zu kommen dann gibt es
nur relativ wenige Möglichkeiten das zu
unterbinden auch Extremisten können Land
kaufen oder versuchen Mitglieder einer
Genossenschaft zu werden doch
Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner wollen
verhindern dass die Verfassungsfeinde im
Dorf Fuß fassen sie gründen einen Verein
organisieren in Vorrunden zu
reichsbürgern und
verschwörungserzählungen
wir wollen eben Antworten haben wie man
sich dem entgegenstellen kann vor allen
Dingen auch als einzelner Bürger mit
diesen Menschen als Nachbarn wir leben
hier seit generationsmittel zusammen und
jetzt wollen sie hier Leute unter uns ja
ansiedeln die wir hier nicht haben
möchten ne wenn sich vor Ort engagierte
Bürgerinnen und Bürger finden die sagen
wir wollen diese Nachbarn nicht dann bin
ich als Bürgermeister natürlich absolut
Berufen diese Leute so gut wie es geht
zu unterstützen ja den Räume zu geben
dass sie sich treffen können vielleicht
Finanzmöglichkeiten zu finden es gibt
Förderprogramme ja aber auch alleine
mich dahinter zu stellen zu sagen ich
stehe an eurer Seite ich bin eben nicht
neutral einiges ist in Rotenberg bereits
umgesetzt politikverwaltung und Bürger
haben sich verletzt sehen den Umgang mit
den reichsbürgern als gemeinsamer
Aufgabe an
so ein erklärtes Ziel weg mit den
reizbürgern aus Gutenberg mal schauen
vielleicht schaffen wir das ja aber
vielleicht auch nur dass sie sich nicht
weiter aussehen kann
so zeigt das Beispiel Rotenberg wie eine
aktive und konsequente Entgegnung auf
Reichsbürger aussehen kann
[Musik]